bonsoir d'actifs
j'ai confiance en monsieur njawe rouler
jacky que vous me prêtez l'oreille
monsieur jack pas nous écouter jacques
clip
cette motion jeu je ne sais rien de vous
viens voir les comédiens et les
musiciens voir les magiciens qui lui
arrive bien rester barman jacky sa
manche la chaîne
charles calais pour vous le premier lieu
associés aux vacances berck plage
ces hausses à berck plage c'est ta cote
est à côté de moi merlimont plage c'est
tout en haut de sueur normandie alors
moi j'avais les jambes arquées 1 et à
l'époque quand on avait des déficiences
dans les eaux on envoyait les enfants à
berck plage pour le bonheur pour le pour
le bonheur et ça m'a remis les gens de
droite
la quête points mais les gens bruit vous
ai des souvenirs de bande de copains de
grosses bêtises avec les copains à berck
non à merlimont non plus n'ont pas
tellement j'ai toujours été un enfant un
petit peu sérieux comme on a eu un passé
assez haché difficile alors on est con
et et les enfants sérieux qu on nous
disait toujours plus attention pour se
faire remarquer on a été bien reçue dans
ce pays tenez vous bien et s'étire
l'instant je tenais bien on se tenant
bien manger pour leur chose vous ai des
souvenirs d'amours de vacances petite
fille sur la plage comme ça à berck où
elle est allée même rame serre a
commencé très tard votre premier baiser
sac et l'asie en 12 ans à 12 ans rue
jean royer est d'aider des chansons de
cette époque qui vous ont marqué alors y
en a plein c'est quoi par exemple les
gars de la marine marine l etoile égale
la naïve joue les gars de la marine
quand on est dans ses urines et là bas
quand j'ai pression assure-t-il
quelles études dans ma vie du fils me
demande de chanter une chanson je chante
et marianne l'a1 et on me dit qu'on vous
a plu jsd orient si j'étais vous rien à
l'époque en voyant leur chanter moi la
marseillaise
on pensait que je connaissais pas la
marseillaise j'ai réussi à en sortir
quelques couplets quand même pas mal
oui parce qu'il ya eu peu de français
qui ne le savaient et l'adolescent
c'était quoi vos vacances aux vacances
de rétention pourquoi parce qu'on
n'avait pas les moyens
je crois que les premières vacances qui
sont les premières vacances on les a eus
à 13 ans j'ai encore une photo de mes
parents et d'un groupe
baignant dans l'eau jusqu'à la ceinture
et que le poing levé parce que c'était
le front populaire et que c'étaient les
premières vacances payées vous avez déjà
des chansons dans la tête à cette époque
oui j'avais déjà écrit une chanson avec
ma soeur avait fait la musique j'avais
fait les paroles j'avais première
chanson j'ai écrites quand j'avais 7 8
ans c'est une histoire d'une voiture
amphibie qui parle qui allait sur l'eau
et sur la terre je me souviens plus très
bien mais ma fille ma soeur s'en
souvient alors des fois elles mêmes à
leur appel
aujourd'hui vos vacances c'est quoi
c'est un drop et saint tropez uniquement
uniquement j'ai fait le tour du monde
plusieurs fois j'ai vu les plus beaux
coins du monde
bon je me suis arrêté à acapulco
thaïlande un petit peu partout la
floride la californie le plus beaux
coins du monde c'est d'abord sur la
méditerranée bon c'est aussi la corse
bien sûr mais moi je me sens plus à
l'aise ici ça me permet de voyager
d'aller encore servir et l'or est resté
une maison à saint tropez et vous
trouvez pas que la région est un peu
galvaudé quand même donc la région est
très très construit très bâti que vous
tapez frelaté l'était saint tropez dans
le var
d'abord le beurre est très bien
préservés d'autre part saint tropez
c'est l'auberge espagnole vous voulez
vous éclatez vous éclater voulait rester
au calme ou rester au calme voulait leur
un coin particulier vous pouvez y aller
vous faites ce que vous voulez à ses 1,3
que des gens qui viennent me dire on va
pourra se produire si à trop de monde ce
n'est pas vrai il ya du monde sur le
port et gain de visiter puis repart si
vous voulez vivre normalement vous
pourrez vivre en famille tout à fait
normalement mais vous qu'est ce qu'est
la première chose que vous faites quand
vous arrivez en vacances prochains jours
d'abord je n'arrête pas de travailler
pendant huit jours
un bon je sais pas il
les choses à faire dans une maison qu'on
n'a pas abandonné pendant un an donc je
fais toujours plein de choses et il faut
tout revoir pour refaire et mes vacances
commencent lorsque tout est terminé
hélas au bout de huit jours qu'est ce
que vous faites après en vacances je
fais pas grand chose le matin j'ai écrit
un petit peu vu et puis je descends sur
le sur le port parce qu'il ya pas
beaucoup de monde le matin là je prends
mon journal je vais au bistrot je
rencontre les journalistes
habituellement ils sont plus là on peut
faire une photo je dis non d'ailleurs
régulièrement réservé beaucoup en
vacances des journalistes
il me fiche la paix ouais on se connaît
depuis très longtemps et le côté
paparazzi ça n'existe surtout si on n'a
pas tellement exister en france et c'est
vrai alors ses horaires comme ça serait
très sérieux voix de déjeuner à 2h de
vous coucher tout vous coucher vers
quelle heure je sois les jeunes à 12h30
je me couche vers 10h30
ah ouais avec un bouquin mais là je
bouquine jusqu'à minuit à bhl ou alors
j'ai des choses à apprendre à mémoriser
je le fais le soir dans mon lit c'est là
qu'on apprend le mieux vous sentez pas
dans les boîtes
non j'ai eu mon temps ouais qu'est ce
que vous faites on vous fait rien alors
dans la journée non mais je n'arrive pas
à lorient tient bon donc j'ai toujours
quelque chose
par exemple je n'ai pas envoyé toujours
un quick a réparé abri car boire
quelqu'un rencontré quelque chose à
écrire un coup de téléphone à donner non
non j'ai toujours quelques affaires
faites du sport en vacances n'ont pas de
sport non bonjour bull
non les gem au casino non non je suis
pas joueur devait pas jouer un ancien
alors pour un oriental pas du tout
faites des siestes n'ont jamais n'ont
même pas des siestes crapuleuses ce que
l'été c'est la grande spécialité quand
même pour orienter
quel est votre meilleur accessoire de
repos l'été le sable le livre le hamac
n'y en a pas mais pas il en dit vous
devez pas vous allonger sur la plage en
matière est produite je ne me mets pas
au soleil
ouais je vis au soleil parce que
finalement ce qu'il faut c'est profiter
du soleil mais se mettre au soleil
brille en est même qui ont un truc en
moins sur le coup comme ça et près du
soleil plein la figure et puis à la fin
de leur bilan et agents tous les ans
nous fait passer avons regardé j'ai pas
d'opération univers parfait je sais pas
mais bien c'est très en forme et votre
femme
elle va bien merci